today's one minute Monday is stop
planning and start doing starting the
business is gonna be one of the most
exciting and also scariest things that
you ever do in your life I think of it
as having your first child and when
you're when you're becoming a parent you
do a lot of planning but then when you
walk out of that hospital holding on to
your first child you are scared you feel
like you're not prepared you're not
ready for this like they're trusting you
to walk out of a hospital with this new
child and you're supposed to know what
you're supposed to do it's scary and a
lot of entrepreneurs they plan they plan
they plan they plan they plan you plan
your business to death I remember
spending an entire summer writing a plan
for my business and as soon as I started
testing that everything fell apart my
assumptions are wrong the plan didn't
work I had to adjust the planning can be
important but you don't want to plan so
much that you never actually do anything
because the results are gonna come from
acting so the next time that you come
with an idea see I want to try this I
wouldn't be cool if we could do this
with the company stop writing it down
stop doing your research stop creating
Excel files stop preparing it in this
folder that you're never going to look
at later on and do act on it try
something reach out to somebody find a
low-risk way to test it out to start
getting some some metric to see if your
assumptions are right or wrong to see if
you enjoy to see if you're getting
momentum with it stop planning and start
doing believe don't forget to click here
to subscribe to my newsletter to get
actionable inspiring motivational
believe advice every single week to your
inbox hi I'm Jason Grif on sigur rós
online.com and I want to say Evan
Carmichael's newsletter is consistent
fun inspiring and it's the only
newsletter i prioritize and look forward
to period